لا احد يريد حدوث مواجهات بين روسيا وحلف
النيتو ولكن اذا اراد احد فنحن مستعدون
يرفعون رايه العداء لاوكرانيا تتحرك لتغلق
بولندا حدودهما والتوترات تشتعل والسعوديه
تفتح الباب على مصراعيه امام كييفل السلام
وبوتين يرحب وطائرات كييف الانتحاريه تجد
طريقها نحو موسكو ليغلق الروس المطار
ويعلن حاله الطوارئ والكرملين يحرك اقوى
جيوشه فما الذي يجري والصين تزرع قنبله
موقوته في الولايات المتحده والجيش
الامريكي في خطر ومواطنو النيجر يطردون
الجيش الفرنسي ويغلقون السفاره ويرفعون
على روسيا وبعد تصريحات بايدن لعاب تل
ابيب
بسبب الرياض
بوتين يستدعي مفترسات المحيط بعد ان اطمئن
على سير المعارك في الاراضي الاوكرانيه
ذهب الرئيس الروسي ليريح راسه قليلا من
صداع الحرب والمعارك بوتين احتفل مع
اسطوله البحري بيوم البحريه الروسيه
بمدينه سانت بطرسبورغ وهناك اعلن عن اطلاق
بلاده 30 سفينه بحريه حربيه من مختلف
الفئات خلال العام الجاري وضمها للاسطول
البحري الروسي فمرحبا بمفترسات المحيط
وبهذه المناسبات
هديته للبلدان الافريقيه بقوله ان موسكو
ستبدا بارسال الحبوب الروسيه المجانيه
اليها خلال ثلاثه الى اربعه اشهر بوتين لم
يكتفي بذلك بل وجه عرضا خاصا لجميع دول
العالم وعلى طريقه البعث المتجولين في
الشوارع قائلا لدينا اسمده في موانئ
البلطيق ونحن على استعداد
مجانا للبلدان المحتاجه ولكنهم لا يسمحون
باخراجها ليعلنها
فتحه بان لا احد يريد حدوث مواجهه بين
روسيا وحلف الناتو ولكن اذا اراد احد فنحن
مستعدون وفق قوله يا جامد وكما يقولها
المصريون اخذ الحق بالدراع صنع لنكمل من
جهته قال نائب رئيس مجلس الامن الروسي
لمترم انه يجب ان يتضرع اعداء روسيا للرب
كي يوافق المقاتلين الروس في مهمتهم لان
خساره الجيش الروسي تعن اشتعال نيران
الحرب النوويه العالميه وكانه يضع الغرب
امام خيارين احلاهما مرتيما ان ينتصر
الجيش الروسي ويخسر الغرب او ان يخسر
الروس وهناك ستندلع الحرب النووي واذا كان
الخيار لكييه فهي تختار الحرب على الدوام
حيث وجد الاوكرانيون طريقهم نحو اختراق
الاجواء الروسيه بالطائرات المسيره وهنا
وللمره الثانيه ومن جديد اعلنت وزاره
الدفاع الرو احباط هجوم نفذه نظام كييف
بواسطه طائرات مسيره على منشات في موسكو
ما ادى الى اغلاق احد المطارات الرئيسيه
في العاصمه لفتره وجيزه مهلا مهلا هذه
الاخبار هي من العيار الثقيل ويجب ان ناتي
لكم بالمصدر احبطت محاولته هجوم ارهابيا
لنظام كييف بطائرات بلا طيار على اهداف في
مدينه موسكو وكالعاده فجيش موسكو
الالكتروني السيبراني هو من يتولى المهمه
حيث عادت الدفاع الروسيه لتعلن احباط هجوم
اخر للاوكران بواسطه 25 مسيره على اهداف
في شبه جزيره القرم دون وقوع اصابات موضحه
انه تم تدمير 16 مسيره اوكرانيه بنيران
انظمه الدفاع الجوي بينما تم تعطيل 9
مسيرات اوكرانيه اخرى بوسائط الحرب
الالكترونيه دون ان تصل الى الهدف فتحطمت
في البحر الاسود
في غرب شبه الجزيره لياتي الرد الروسي على
لسان وزاره الدفاع الروسيه والتي اعلنت عن
مقتل سبعمائه وخمسه وعشرين عسكريا
اوكرانيا في عمليات للقوات الروسيه خلال
24 ساعه واكدت الوزاره اسقاط مروحيه
اوكرانيه من طراز
وتدمير 44 طائره مسيره في مناطق متفرقه
والارقام ليست وليده افكارنا بل كما هي من
المصدر الذي تشاهدونه امامكم بينما تستقبل
الضربه هذه المره من حيث لم تتوقع حيث
كشفت صحيفه ان الملياردير الامريكي ايلون
ماسك
اوكرانيا حق الوصول الى شبكه بالقرب من
شبه جزيره القرم الروسيه وبالتالي فسيكون
من الصعب جدا على الطائرات الاوكرانيه
والصواريخ ضرب الاهداف بدقه كونها تنطلق
بطريقه
وغير موجهه وهنا فتحت السعوديه احضانها
امام الاوكران لتكشف صحيفه
ستستضيف في اغسطس المقبل محادثات بشان
ازمه اوكرانيا وستشارك فيها الى جانب
مسؤولين من نحو 30 دوله اتي ذلك فيما اكد
الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين انه يمكن
البناء على المبادرتين الافريقيه والصينيه
للتحقيق السلام واذا كان بوتين منفتحا
للسلام فماذا عن زلنسكيب رايكم رئيس
الاوكراني من جهته ذهب الى مواقع متقدمه
للقوات الاوكرانيه قرب مدينه بخموت التي
تشهد معارك عنيفه لتفقدها وذلك بمناسبه
اليوم الوطني لقوات العمليات الخاصه وماذا
عن عرض الرياضيه هذا ومن اوكرانيا بدات
الحرب تنزح وتتسع نحو الدول المجاوره فمع
ازدياد اعداد قوات بيلاروسيا ان بولندا
وليتوانيا المجاورتين تدرسان اغلاق الحدود
لمنع تسلل فاقنر الى اراضيهما والتسبب
بزعزعه الاستقرار حيث اعلنت وارسو ان اكثر
من 100 مقاتل من فاجنر اتجهوا نحو ممر سوى
الكليستراتيجي بين بولندا وليتوانيا محذره
من انهم قد يتنكرون في صفه مهاجرين
ليعبروا حدود بلادها ومنها نحو الاتحاد
الاوروبي فما الذي تخطط له بطن يا ترى ولا
زلنا في بولندا حيث رفعت الجماهير
البولنديه لافتات تحمل شعارات معاديه
لاوكرانيا ماثر فضيحه صاخبه خلال مباراه
لكره القدم لنادي شليس من مدينه فروتساف
بحسب الصحيفه
هل يمهد البولنديون بهذه الافعال لاستعاده
اراضيهم من اوكرانيا من يدري ما الذي
يخبئه الزمن
الاحداث والتطورات
افادت صحيفه نيويورك تايمز ان الاداره
الامريكيه تعتقد ان الصين زرعت برمجيات
خبيثه في شبكات كهرباء واتصالات رئيسيه
امريكيه تشكل قنبله موقوته يمكن ان تؤذي
الجيش الامريكي في حال النزاع او حال
تحركت بكين ضد تايوان في وقت ما والاجهزه
المتضرره وفق الصحيفه يمكن ان تسمح للصين
ليس فقط بقطع الكهرباء والاتصالات عن
قواعد عسكريه امريكيه انما عن منازل
وشركات في انحاء الولايات المتحده ايضا
بعد ان كشف بايدن عن اتفاق مع السعوديه
ربما يكون قريبا بشان اسرائيل قال رئيس
الوزراء الاسرائيلي
ان تل ابيب تعمل على ربط السعوديه وشبه
الجزيره العربيه باسرائيل عبر خط سكك
حديديه فهل تقبل المملكه بذلك الى النيجر
وبعد الانقلاب على الرئيس محمد بازو طالبا
الاتحاد الافريقي الجيش بالعوده الى
سكناته واعاده السلطات الدستوريه خلال 15
يوما بينما اوضح الاتحاد الاوروبي انه لا
يعترف ولن يعترف بسلطات الانقلاب في
النيجر وانه يعلق فورا كل تعاونه في
المجال الامني مع الدوله الافريقيه بينما
تجمع الاف المتظاهرين المؤيدين للانقلاب
العسكري في النيجر امام السفره الفرنسيه
في العاصمه النيجيريا حسبما ذكرت وكاله
الفرنسي عرضا ويرفع علم روسيا قايلين تحيا
روسيا ولتسقط فرنسا
[موسيقى]